- Are you going to get a
chance to sing on the show?
Is my question.
- The "Grownish" show or this show?
- No "Grownish"
- Oh all right.
- All right, this show too!
What!
Get a mike!
(laughing)
- No I don't sing on grownish.
- You don't?
- My character would not do that.
- He would not?
Okay, maybe you just work it in somehow.
Maybe you surprise people, yeah.
I'm just saying you're really good at it.
- Sit on the toilet or something.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] In the shower.
(laughing)
- I love that you went with the toilet
instead of the shower.
- I don't know why!
- Hey I love the toilet,
that's the best place.
You got a lot of time.
- Yes.
I find a lot of inspiration sitting there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] You know why?
'Cause as a parent, it's
your only alone time.
(laughing)
- Only alone time!
- It's like, I stay in there
way longer than I need to.
- [Trevor] Yeah, yeah.
- "Still working it out!"
(laughing)